ist das bloß verzweiflung oder ist das
schon prostitution was der wendler jetzt
damit seiner laura so macht er
verschuldet bis zum gehtnichtmehr will
jetzt im internet mit dem körper seiner
laura geld machen den nackten körper
natürlich die geschäftsidee die wendlers
sind bei der bezahlplattform oli fans
angekommen während hier posten so
genannte promis nackt bilder und videos
von sich sehr viel promo grafisches zeug
und die fans die sollen dann dafür
zahlen bei lars und 30 euro im monat für
das komplettpaket
250 euro im jahr ja und so wird laura
schon mal selbst für ihren neuen job
und manche sagen auch bei den händlern
feeds aber das war diesmal nicht lauras
schuld sondern unsere also laura sagt
jedenfalls sie wirkt bei insta einfach
nur zu only fans zu kommen und zu sagen
hier hier kommt was hier gibt es
demnächst private einblick ist etwa mal
schauen was ist auch die fans eigentlich
warum machen die wendlers das wie tief
sind sie gesunken und das wird uns jetzt
bild chefin tanja maria erklären schön
dass du bei uns ist was ist da los bei
den wenn das ja hallo ihr beiden ja ich
sage mal schlimmer geht immer vor den
wendlers und das ist für mich jetzt der
absolute tiefpunkt den die beiden
erreicht haben diese sony fans ist ja
nichts anderes als seine sechs plattform
und das ist ich sag mal so wie spotify
du zahlst du beitrag im monat und
bekommst musik dafür geliefert und bei
uni fans ist es so du zahlst einen
beitrag dafür wie du sagst 30 bis 250
euro im monat und dafür kannst du dir
jetzt die nackten hintern angucken von
lauda oder teilweise auch wirklich
pornografische fotos der sind auch
einige prominente dort vertreten ja und
ich frage mich natürlich aber warum
machen die leute das also warum stellen
die diese fotos da rein und b was hat
mich jetzt davon dass ich geld dafür
bezahlt um den nackten hintern von
irgendjemand zu sehen gut die geschichte
dieser plattform zeigt es gibt durchaus
eine nachfrage danach offenbar auch
gegen geld aber wie dicht ist das dann
schon an der prostitution was der
wendler damit der laura macht für mich
ganz klar prostitution was er macht er
verkauft seine frau er verkauft fotos
seiner frau er zeigt ja den playboy den
ich übrigens sehr geschmackvoll fand als
ich als sie es gemacht hat diese
aufnahme playboy fand ich ganz toll
leider ist ein bildhübsches also die
bildhübsche junge frau aber dass er die
jetzt da rein stellt und dafür geld
kassiert ist nichts anderes als absolut
prostitution man muss ja sagen damals
als sie zusammen gekommen sind da war
der wendler selber die große
gelddruckmaschine da waren auch groß im
business offensichtlich hat sich das
blatt ja jetzt komplett gewendet was
sagt diese aktionen über die wendlers
aus wie tief sind wir gesunken wobei sie
zusammen gekommen sind da war er ja
eigentlich schon abgeschrieben und sie
hat dann aber so eine blitzkarriere
hingelegt die laura bei let's dance bei
rtl
und die hatte wirklich eine große
karriere vor sich also ich bin sicher
dass der sender sehr viel mit ihr
gearbeitet hätten auch andere sender sie
gerne gab hätten bis er dann komplett
durchgedreht ist mit seinem corona
geschwurbel und dann sind ja nach
amerika gegangen er ist pleite ganz klar
und sie macht alles mit und da muss ich
sagen am anfang hatte ich mitleid mit
ihr weil ich dachte er hat ihr wirklich
alles kaputt gemacht aber wenn ich diese
fotos erzählen die fans muss ich sagen
okay sie macht das mit sie findet es
lustig und sie steht zu ihm aber kommt
man dann aus dieser uni fans ecke später
noch mal raus oder ist das jetzt im
grunde ganz unten kann sein dass sie ein
bisschen geld damit noch macht aber
damit verbaut sie sich alles andere also
bevor ich gerade zu echten studio kam
habe ich noch mal geguckt da waren es 44
abonnenten die da abgeschlossen waren
das ist ja jetzt nicht viel also wenn du
das mal hochrechnet dafür sich dann
diese blöße zu geben und sich so
lächerlich zu machen und wirklich im
wahrsten sinne des wortes alles
offenzulegen für diese kleine summe geld
muss ich sagen für mich ganz peinlich
und ganz ganz schlimm und ich glaube
wenn du da gelandet bist bei only fans
wird schwierig dann wieder auf eine
höhere stufe zu kommen
allerdings müssen natürlich auch die
ganzen bringe louis vuitton sachen die
sie immer fleißig kauft ja auch
irgendwie finanziert werden und
technisch läuft sie aber den beiden
offensichtlich nicht mehr also
eigentlich eine verzweiflungstat fast
muss man sagen oder er tut so als wenn
das cool fände sie lacht auch sie findet
auch im moment cool nach außen hin
zumindest aber wir haben ja letzte woche
vor ein paar tagen hatten wir die fotos
dass er eine neue chanel tasche gekommen
hat die hat sie dann wiederum vorgestern
zum verkauf angeboten also irgendwie
muss die kohle rein kommen die sind
einfach pleite das ist so und wir wissen
ja hat über eine million schulden auch
eure schulden und aber jetzt mit diesem
only fans also ich glaube außer
image-verlust
ist da nicht viel im moment ja
imageverlust ist noch mal spannend also
ist auch laura wendler sowieso aber ist
auch laura damit verbrannt endgültig von
der will niemand mehr was ich glaube
wenn es also wenn ich mich jetzt
entscheiden müssen zwischen ihr und ihm
dann würde ich immer lauter nehmen ganz
klar die s21 also ich meine der kammer
auch noch erklären was man tun sollte
und was man lassen sollte dem wenn da
kannst du gar nichts mehr erklären und
von daher würde ich sagen bei ihr ist es
nicht aussichtslos bei ihm sage ich ja
was müsste sie denn tatsächlich machen
um ihren ruf jetzt wieder herzustellen
naja dieses format let's dance das war
toll da hat sie sich auch gezeigt dass
sie tanzen kann und wie sympathisch ist
und sie ist ja eine bildhübsche frau und
sie kann ja auch was also das hat sie da
gezeigt und ich denke so ein format
müsste sie auch wieder machen aber so
lange halt immer weiß wenn du leider
buchst bist du automatisch den wendler
mit und der ist eine tickende zeitbombe
also der mark unterhaltsam sein in
gewissen phasen aber letztendlich man
weiß ja nie wieder reagiert und was du
dir da ein hohes in den sender hinein
und deswegen so lange die beiden
zusammen sind glaube ich wird es schwer
haben ihre eigene karriere
voranzutreiben
wer tummelt sich noch da auf dieser
plattform wien sieht man da noch das
heißt da sind promis unterwegs kann ich
mir ganz schwer vorstellen dass da eine
große riege deutscher promis sich da
tummelt an dass man die a- und b-klasse
traum ist natürlich nicht ich würde
sagen er so cd ist da natürlich
vertreten also ein beispiel der herr j
zum beispiel der hat ja auch alles dann
aber gezeigt von sich also das ist eben
die nächste stufe also dass du dann
wirklich blank schießt und da wirklich
porno fotos von dir hinein stellst und
je höher je mehr du zeigst desto mehr
geld kannst du natürlich auch kassieren
diese plattform klingt dann also so ein
bisschen nach youporn für prominente
genau das ist nichts anderes als ein
porno als eine porno plattform also das
ist der neueste versuch der wendler die
schuldner bisschen zu tilgen ein
bisschen geld noch mal ran zu kommen
dafür also verkauft er wendler jetzt den
körper beziehungsweise fotos und videos
des nackten körpers von laura danke für
deinen besuch hier bei uns heute abend
ja ja gerne ihre beiden